tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo rovini
io sono fan di j
non so perché sto tenendo gli occhi
chiusi però ogni volta che faccio la
intro mi vien da chiudere gli occhi come
se mi stesse sputando un cammello
nell'occhio
però va bene sono felice oggi siamo
trovati su itunes come ogni domenica tra
l'altro ragazzi la prossima domenica non
ci sarà è finita perché parola live che
vi avevo promesso che dovevo fare tipo
ieri però lo spostata a domenica
prossima quindi domenica prossima e non
ci sarà è quindi che l'anticipo e agli
occhi pulsar culo al primo livello
ragazze andiamo su artur
già il fatto che gli altri anni nello
scorso episodio mi hanno scassato le
balle che la metà basta e vedo che la
cosa non candita altro sangue nuovo e
veramente filo ci sono voluti 90 episodi
per farmi mettere il sangue
lo zio ecco questa si chiama arte avete
presente l'arte queste altre le segue
intera opera d'arte ladies quartet e di
fa vige risposte alle tante un valore di
4 milioni di dollari d'altra ghazi sarà
si guarda in un certo senso sembra anche
un pene sta diventando sempre più strano
è così perché non fate domande per
cortesia
ok c'è solo un al fassi la fiore le culo
va bene sanno vinto le mani c'è qualcosa
che devo fare no va bene non va bene ma
ragazzi non li super ostico e inutile
che che tentano ok
porca eva sono io sono io staccati
staccati vita ammazzo ti ammazzo
ci sono ancora due arpioni non sono
ancora in salvo e potrei prenderla nel
deretano molto presto papà ancora lo
sapevo lo sapevo che così quella roba lì
che simulano è il pogo da un arpione
staff asa penzolando un arpione sul mio
intestino fantastico no ragazzi
veramente erano parole è impossibile
salta lurido ma non ci credo sono ancora
fermi fermi
non arriveremo prima o poi al centesimo
episodio di hoepli se no perché secondo
me spacco qualcosa prima ragazzi sto
sviluppando un senso di odio incredibile
per gli arpioni ve lo dico c'è una roba
tutto nell'ano mezz'ora per far stare a
mezzo cos'è santa stanchiamo happy meals
stampiamo per che cos'è sta roba le
ragazze questo era solo il primo livello
reflections riflette un qualcosa che
riflette che bello potrebbe essere così
romantico sono mi facesse incazzare vero
zio qui lo devo preoccuparmi perché
tutto riflesso nel senso che il
pavimento rifletto il soffitto e che
cazzo me ne frega a me ma che ci ha
riflesso sulla peeling e finto non
svolazza me ne sono accorto non mi
prendi per il culo morgan dai frati a un
livello tranquillo almeno questo niente
niente
porca eva piano ho finalmente sorridersi
short ma guardava bene perché coloro
passato prima mi serviva un po di relax
faib un dolce hard il primo era semplice
adesso c'è quello hard che più difficile
devo cosa farci ai tuoi muoio e cosa
faccio piano ragazzi ci fosse meglio è
solo all pioli ultimamente è previsto e
non capito perché sono ancora vivo eva
purché lo sai come ti riduco così non ho
adesso lo finisco visto perché ever
cos'è sta roba quando si dice avere la
faccia da culo
ho capito io però non ricorrano niente
ragazzi niente devono server
ok ok calmi sono io sono vivo come
faccio a salire come salgono però se
salgo muoio è un problema questo la cosa
divertente che mi è rimasto il poc
incastrato liquidi non posso neanche
riprenderlo per salire [ __ ] la carica
c'è un livello del genere che è
indecoroso una roba indecente l'arpione
li deve essere sempre piantato sono
o ancora vivo però non so perché non
salta come un mongoloide forse perché ci
ha due piani nel collo solo non ci credo
ma non è possibile allora ragazzi ce la
posso fare
non è così di fitna è difficile nodi più
problema che continua a morire in tutti
i modi ce lo faccia basta non voglio più
sapere gli arpioni non ne voglio più
sapere basta è pura netbook gaga the air
punto a nonna basta machete kilim la
solita che devo annunciare il machete il
problema secolo zio che bene anche tanto
è che non lo becco mai così sono
tagliato una fetta di culo che sta
ancora per terra però lui se ne va a
tanto è una giornata come un'altra
tra l'altro arrivato all'affetto di culo
adesso rimane ci voleva tempo per sa che
grazie questa è la fetta di culo
bellissime se possiamo riavviarlo così
almeno li faccio il culetto grazie bella
zio ragazzi facciamo buoni livelli con i
normali cioè in teoria allora questi
sono i livelli quelli più votati in
assoluto solo che non li faccio mai
perché vado sempre sul browser
ok rain eyes hands free today dove vado
ma è un parco giochi celio che ti
diverti è bravo attenta a non farsi
pizzicare le mani bravo zio che sei
pronto per giocare se hai voglia perché
è saltato prendiamo i cerotti zio
prendiamocela pip con un cerotto per il
bambino per cortesia grazie che si è
fatto male ecco le donna dalle un
cerotto postare a leggere il giornale
quello se scassato un braccio mi ricordo
ragazzi se avevo già giocato suo livello
non mi pare non credo è morto
basta che si diventa mi dissi però
qualcosa milita almeno è venuta bene la
foto zia mi tagli su instagram sono fa
vj set fa vigenti ai cavalli ci sono
suddivisi che bel cavallo tra i nomi no
vabbè se i serio sono messo molto bene
per il combattimento a cavallo vai sei
morto zio vinto io e se anche scarso
perché ho pure giocato coi piedi guarda
un po che non town
questo mi sembra carino non lo so è
entrato linee la città dei cannoni che
non sono quelli che ti spari ma sono
quelli che sparano vero zio credo
sfondato un vetro vabbè sono ancora vivo
sono ancora vivo importante arrivare
alla fine del livello se sei riesco e
poi non so
giusto poso fare sto scivolo anch'io mi
diverte c'era una macchina perché per
uccidermi c'era un motivo
alla fine ragazzi sono molto forte secca
perché tanto non ce la farò bootcamp
[Musica]
goodbyes extreme che non so che cosa
voglia dire cut l'unica casa che quindi
sky ma cosa fai
ah ah ok a nolo guido io il bus io
faccio solo la spaccata che bella
posizione riccione no no stai dentro
perché c'è il tettuccio sono morto che
bello vabbè dai facciamo finta di non
essere morto io cosa succedeva niente
bello è un bus e c'era una palla che ha
appena passata sapete cosa altre passata
la mia pazienza
non so se si vede arkema almeno questi
che sono livelli scelti ma fateli belli
monte miami sarò io faccio la storia
dell'uomo che volava e che guidava gli
autobus che i ragazzi sono l'uomo che
finiva sugli autobus che bello siamo in
svizzera non l'avrebbero aprendo la
normale che si è fermato perché se no
devo prendere col culo tanto sembra un
piccone di legno di minecraft perché è
un addio davis allevare bravo
no perché sapete cosa altro è passata
oltre che la mia pazienza la mia voglia
di vivere allora devi stare devi stare
de vista bra adesso ti puoi muoverti
adesso sì che puoi farlo però mica prima
fetta ho buttato cioè scusa ho buttato
giù degli alberi così a caso però vado
andare dove voglio io vado ributto qua
davanti che c'è la slitta di babbo
natale
allora slitterà prima bello posso vedere
casa mia da qui posso anche vedere il
pianeta dvd di rieti per questa ricetta
di stare stai fermo no oddio ragazzino
sostituisce è pazzo bravo zio bravo
perfetto ecco adesso adesso puoi uscire
bravissimi giù come una valanga scusa
lio che non volevo giuro io sono vivo
perso solo le braccia aperte
questo era un livello buttato giù 200
alberi non lo so perché sono anche
tornate le mani 10 su 10
wipeout no voi fatto era bellissimo
guardavano piccolo ma è quello che penso
dai che figo e rom per costi posti era
tipo takeshi's castel un tempo però non
è proprio che forse un po più sanguinoso
questo che figata no vabbè i giochi sono
gli stessi ragazzi sono uguali mi chiamo
ri troppo fanno un wipe out nella vita
reale grande tsunami ecco infatti quella
un po più sanguinoso che allora ragazzi
se non riesco stavolta non riesco più
quindi o magra può magra niente o è
partita prima sentite basta mi sono
rotto i [ __ ]
se non con un tiro di surraco zio ancora
una corona spingiti bravissimo
bravissimo mio dio ci arrivò così ecc
[Musica]
che l'ha fatta ragazzi facciamo finta il
filetto e che non o guasti livelli sono
peggio di quelli normali lasciano bella
facciamo un paio di miei visto che
faccio facci geni faccini esiste a
livello facci già imposti col se c'è la
festa in un gran baraja che l'ho trovato
rifarci j
la vedo dura però fa cj imposti con sé
uno sballo mi piace non andare qui come
tanto come ci arrivo non sono un
superman dall aspetta un attimo che devo
capire affetto adesso la l'angolo
fatti ea ragazza 22 secondi e 77 record
dei record dei gesuiti attivo ragazzi
cosa sbagliare il nome voglio vedere se
c'è qualcosa vige invece csit così fa
vigeva vige interrogato parte 1 spiegami
il senso di sta roba
jafari spero che questo mio livello non
ti piace infatti fa abbastanza schifo
metti la musica di summer di calvin
harris per portarti fortuna nel livello
no perché poi metà volevi farmi mettere
copyright al e video su capitoli trovano
questa roba non posso leggere frate
perché se mi fermo crepo tremila volte
quindi va beh beh bello mi è piaciuto
questo livello bello grazie mi più
grazie a prezzo prezzo molto belli fa
vince dai 6.000 metri spiega mi sta roba
500 metri cosa vuol dire fatto
scientemente che servizio anche tra un
po mi c'è un dosso e mi butto giù e
faccio skydiving fammi capire un tot
sensi va zio mi mette ansia questi
numeri fa mi fai vedere che devo fare
via 6.000 metri
tu non dovevi fare i livelli di api
dovevi fare il m come il ruolo perché
non è così
quelli erano a 6.000 metri perché mi
sembrava più lunga la tratta che ho
fatto prima di arrivare al burrone non
farlo al metro stavo scherzando final
tra ragazzi non ho trovato ultimamente
un senso a questa vita fa vj cubo killer
dai facciamo sotto questa veste migliaia
certo l'ansia in corpo era meglio sono
guarda voi non avete visto non ho fatto
niente andiamo ti prego perfetto grazie
si cucina se segnassi concludo episodio
lasciamo stare tutto ma che ha mai avuto
un senso storia diverso e niente non ha
avuto senso niente spero che ha visto vi
sia piaciuto e cosa salito sui video
vincitore sull'argomento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come nell
idea trattare iscrizione cestisti amici
vediamo al prossimo video bello ragazzi